so in Star Wars coming out this week
what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion on the character of kanan
jarrus and what I'm hoping is that at
the end of this video you'll have a
better understanding of his character as
well as how he fits into the overarching
theme of Star Wars as a whole so Kanan
Jara's first appears in Star Wars rebels
episode number one in October of 2014
functioning as a leader of a group of
rebels fighting against the Galactic
Empire Darth Vader and Emperor Palpatine
as a show that took place 14 years after
Episode three five years before Episode
four and served to cover the fallout of
order 66 with the last surviving Jedi
going into hiding rebels was met with
good reviews from fans and critics alike
within the first couple episodes the
stage was effectively set for the basis
behind both Kanan as well as Ezra the de
facto star of the show who was
originally presented as an orphan with
the potential to tap into the force
where the remainder of this series
continued to focus on Kanan taking Ezra
as a Padawan with the duo operating
alongside the rest of the ghost crew and
using guerilla warfare tactics against
the empire in April of 2015 as part of
Disney's acquisition of the Star Wars
rights and the expansion of its in
Universe continuity under the banner of
journey to the force awakens came in the
last Padawan was launched as an ongoing
series with Greg Weitzman working as the
writer as a graduate of Stanford
University with a bachelor's degree in
English Wiseman had worked alongside
writer Carrie Bates on the Captain Atom
series and DC Comics where his other
work came in the form of an unrealized
miniseries starring Black Canary his
time in both the animated and comic-book
landscape also involved early conceptual
design for the gargoyles cartoon show
the European cartoon show which as well
as spectacular spider-man and Young
Justice as a result when Disney took
over the Star Wars series Weiss was
brought on board to help launch came in
the last Padawan to expand on Kanaan's
backstory and operate as a counterpart
to his appearances and Star Wars rebels
having said that were issue number one
followed the crew of the ghost during
one of their missions the story also saw
a series of flashbacks to 15 years prior
during the events of the Clone Wars from
Star Wars Episode two taking place on a
planet called collar their story reveals
the Kayden's actual name is caleb dume
during his time training under the jedi
kenan was taken as a Padawan by Master
Depa billaba
teaching him how to use a third form of
lightsaber combat called cerise ooh or
way of the
my NOC which focuses heavily on defense
rather than offense the two had fought
together leading the forces of the
Republic against general cleave
operating is one of the leaders of the
separatist Confederacy of Independent
Systems because Kanan and his master
were strong in the force and able to
quite literally cut a swath through the
separatist army general Klee was forced
to flee with the Republic taking collar
back under their control and so
following this victory because the
Battle of collar left little room for
depa to Train Caleb adequately the two
took the evening to reconnect and ensure
that he was maintaining his role
alongside the path of light side of the
force
now this tension between the two is of
supreme importance and the reason why is
because it sets the stage for much of
what happens in the remainder of the
series going into Clone Wars were Depa
asked Caleb to describe what he feels
where his initial response is that he
has questions the overall theme deborah
is shooting for is what he feels within
his heart all were told is that for
Caleb prior to becoming a Padawan in the
Jedi Order he had always felt akin to a
leaf blowing in the wind and that he had
no true understanding of his destiny or
any control of where his life was headed
indeed because the galaxy was so large
with so many directions a person's life
to take Caleb's introduction to the Jedi
Order gave him a way to view his destiny
without the distraction of decisiveness
however was newly established feelings
of purpose depe informs Caleb that he
stands on the precipice of danger and
that because he's both inexperienced and
filled with emotion he could potentially
fall to the dark side of the force the
sidetrack for a second within the
official Star Wars universe and the non
official legends material while the Jedi
avoided strong emotions like love hate
fear and anger less powerful emotions
like the feeling that comes with a sense
of belonging were viewed as an asset
like a sidewalk with hedgerows on both
sides these feelings serve as a guide
ensuring that the Jedi stay in tune with
the light side of the force however
because the galaxy waxes and wanes with
the changing times did I have to learn
to adapt and as they continue their
plays within the order the feeling of
purpose would eventually give way to the
feeling of duty but for someone like
Caleb who had never known what it meant
to have a place in the cosmos the fear
of losing this feeling could lead him
down the path of the dark side and
eventual alignment with a Sith Empire
something to also take note of here is
that Caleb's master did not hold
absolute adherence to the Jedi teachings
despite being a member of the Jedi High
Council now this in particular was not
unheard of within the Star Wars universe
what I mean here is that not all July
turned into fallen Jedi and join the
Sith Empire when they disagreed with the
teachings instead where the Jedi as a
whole believed in the light side of the
force and used it as a means to operate
as peacekeepers but in their own ranks
there were varying beliefs in terms of
what the force was and how it related to
the universe as a whole while some
maintain strict adherence to the Living
force which flowed through all things
and used it to focus on the moment
others maintained adherence to the
cosmic force and through it they could
perceive the end result of their destiny
and see the future however for depa her
disagreement with the Jedi isn't based
on her view of the force and instead
it's based on the idea that the Jedi
moved themselves away from their role as
a peacekeeping force isolated from the
galaxy's conflicts and instead became
part and parcel to the military and that
they assigned themselves ranks and
operated accordingly but for the
soldiers who listen to the conversation
between Deborah and Caleb Jedi
involvement in the war and their
adoption of military ranks was as much a
moral rallying call as was a method of
organization and that the separatist
army was highly organized and had
mobilized to present a threat on all
fronts
while the forces of the Galactic
Republic were largely composed as
soldiers clone in the image of a highly
capable soldier but as on to take orders
with no room for self-governance as such
the wisdom of the Jedi was necessary to
ensure a successful campaign lest the
Republic be doomed to failure and
eventual defeat furthermore where most
Jedi continued their following of the
Jedi ideologies
Caleb's desire for answers to questions
a play disk curiosity regarding why the
Jedi followed the rules they did was
what caused depa to take him on as an
apprentice all this didn't mean that she
intended to sow the seeds of dissent and
orchestrate his defection from the Jedi
ranks it did mean that to her Caleb was
a more open mind and that where he
believed in the Jedi way he also
recognized that blindly following the
path of their teachings would not allow
them to adapt to the changing times and
so providing him with a holocron the
information contained within would allow
Caleb to receive the answers to his
questions without openly asking them
aloud and leaving other Jedi to believe
that he harbored the potential to fall
to the dark side however in the midst of
Caleb's instruction by depa
order 66 is implemented by Emperor
Palpatine
which entails eliminating the Jedi who
have been deemed a threat to the
Republic again while this was simply
part of Palpatine's plan to eliminate
all opposition to his ascension as ruler
of the galaxy the fact remains that the
clones surrounding depa and Caleb turn
on them and citing a battle between the
two groups now this scene as is depicted
here is very important because what it
tells us is that order 66 wasn't a
simple matter of the clouds turning on
the Jedi and the Jedi killing them in
turn instead the Jedi considered many of
these soldiers to be their friends and
that they had forged themselves in the
fires of battle fought alongside one
another and save each other's lives on
several occasions but with order 66
while the clones were able to
immediately cast the sentiment aside the
Jedi weren't and in this particular
instance caleb flies himself frozen and
torn between his loyalty to his friends
and his loyalty to the jedi on the other
hand for depe the situation is a simple
matter of fight or flight and in this
instance she's chosen to fight taking up
her life saber against the clones she's
able to clear Caleb from the moment who
in turn chooses his allegiance and
alongside his master attach the clones
now during the fight depe comes to the
realization that because the clones had
referenced order 66 prior to attacking
them this can't be an isolated incident
since they're designed to simply follow
orders as such if these clones have
turned against them it stands to reason
that the rest of the clones have turned
against the Jedi as well and so Ori
Caleb to run with the promise that
she'll follow behind him where he knows
as she's lying he does as he's
instructed and retreats
however after making his way to the top
of the hill it's revealed that like the
remaining Jedi
depe has died at the hands of the clones
now following this with the remaining
three issues go on to establish the
basis behind how it was Kayla met the
rest of the crew from rebels and
undertook the name Kanan because these
first few comics were so successful in
that they consistently broke the top-30
sales list each month with issues number
7 and number 8 in November and December
of 2015
weissman came back and provided the
backstory behind how it was that Kanan
met depa in addition to his training
during the early days of the Clone Wars
picking up and course and with the
younglings under the tutelage of Master
Yoda the events take place one day
before the initiate Ryles decide check
for a second within Star Wars
potential Jedi are usually only taken at
a young age before their minds have the
chance to learn emotions and the
complexity that comes with him during
this time the potential
crews received their instruction in
groups and only after passing the trials
where they granted the role of heroine
and apprentice to a Jedi Master now
because neither Disney nor Marvel have
released any information regarding the
Jedi trials within the new continuity
we're going to have to reference the old
continuity to at least give us some idea
of what they mean the trials of the Jedi
Order actually come in three tests the
first was to memorize and recite the
code of the Jedi and whether had been
several variations over the years the
most popular states that there is no
emotion there is peace there is no
ignorance there is knowledge there is no
passion there serenity there's no chaos
there's harmony there is no death there
is the force now the second test period
over the years and were some of the
expanded universe and film universe
content like Knights of the Old Republic
or Return of the Jedi established the
second tests as being the construction
of a lightsaber other sources like Jedi
path manual for students of the force
required a demonstration and competency
simply using a lightsaber following this
the Jedi hopeful would undergo the third
task which ranged anywhere from helping
a fallen Jedi return to the light side
to demonstrating their connection to the
force but once a Jedi completed the
trials they would go on to choose the
path of a Jedi consular a Jedi Guardian
or a Jedi Sentinel during which time
that would be a printed to a Jedi Master
of the same class now to be clear not
all Jedi recruits would be chosen to
become hata ones instead if for some
reason they were selected due to not
being powerful enough in the force or
because they failed the trials most Jedi
would go on and join the service corps
under one of four branches composed of
agriculture medical educational and
exploration and if you're interested in
learning more about the Jedi as a whole
I'll have a video about that on Rob
explains but within the context of this
story the problem that Caleb faces is
that in addition to his constant need to
question he also lacks focus as a result
during this following session between
himself and the other younglings he's
injured with Master Yoda sitting him to
the infirmary now after his arrival the
destiny of Caleb comes to fruition and
that the intention of Yoda didn't seem
to be fork able to actually receive any
treatment but instead to discover the
recovering body of depa well I wouldn't
say that this was ever confirmed in the
Star Wars universe because Yoda is so
powerful very rarely does he ever act
without having some measure of the
outcome or at least some kind of plan in
terms of how he would like for things to
turn out
to this end when Caleb first encounters
Depa billaba the to Cena form was
referred to as a force bond again this
isn't confirmed but the reaction of
Caleb seems to fit the hallmark of a
force bond what I mean here is that when
this occurs the force presents itself as
a special connection between two
individuals that doesn't represent love
so much as it establishes a bridge
between the very essence allowing for a
kinship of sorts that no one else shares
however shortly after his arrival
he's probably kicked out by the medical
droid and told only to return if he
suffered a mortal injury now to focus on
debt before second her isolation within
the medical bay comes by way of her
battle against General Grievous and the
separatist droid army were not given
much information regarding the nature of
this conflict or exactly how it unfolded
what we do know is that during the
battle depa had suffered intense
injuries leading to her falling into a
coma where she was brought to the Jedi
tip of a recovery and so after awakening
she's met with the arrival of Master
Yoda obi-wan Kenobi and mace Windu now
something I'd like you to notice here is
that unlike the other masters depe is
far more Cavalier regarding her attitude
and overall demeanor and that rather
than being serious she has a bit more
sarcasm about her some a Yoda Mesa and
obi-wan don't fully value at the same
time however the question lingers as to
the toll that the battle and the
subsequent calm has had on depe
to this end the intention of Yoda
obi-wan and mace is to effectively test
the physical mental emotional and
fitness aspects of depe to ensure that
she is made of full recovery and so
picking back up with Caleb we join a
lesson with a Jedi chronicler who's been
expanding the basis behind how the Jedi
selected his Padawan so once they
complete the trials furthermore when we
discussed dep is reasoning behind
choosing caleb ezra padawan she stated
that it was born from his constant
questioning of why the Jedi follow their
traditions now an important distinction
to make here is the difference between
asking why the Jedi followed the
traditions and questioning the actions
of the Jedi themselves through dissent
for Caleb he believes in the Jedi
teachings in his questioning it's simply
the byproduct of his curiosity but
because the other members of his class
who have passed the trials don't share
his same curiosity they view Caleb as an
outlier rather than a genuine Jedi
hopeful in addition to this the view
that Cato's classmates hold of him is
compounded on during a discussion
between the three when he stated in
addition to his help with being selected
by depe he also hopes to have the
opportunity to fight during the Clone
Wars
the reason why this is important is that
if you recall Yoda's explanation of the
Jedi to Luke Skywalker during the Empire
Strikes Back he had stated that the Jedi
do not seek out adventure or excitement
and instead use their power in a
defensive manner to meditate and keep
the peace
however Caleb's continued curiosity
about depa
is also expanded on when he learns from
his fellow classmates but after her
experience in losing so many soldiers in
her battle against Grievous coupled with
falling into a coma
many of the clones have labeled her as
damaged goods and as such view her is
both an incapable leader and Jedi now
where this doesn't deter Caleb from
seeking apprenticeship under debt by
herself it does drive him to bring the
issue to her attention directly and
essentially asking her if she is indeed
damaged goods now this in particular is
another important moment for the tuber
in that because Caleb is so
straightforward with his thoughts and
questions
depa respects this as a compliments her
straightforward nature as well however
before the two can engage in any further
discussion regarding Devas view of
herself by way of her past experiences
the Jedi Temple is set upon by cage
warriors with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
the reason why is because this is
actually the most current issue of Kaine
in the last Padawan and so until the
next issue comes out next month we
actually won't know what happens next
but if you're interested in learning
more about Caden or if you want me to do
future videos on his character as the
storylines progress then leave a comment
below and let me know and I will catch
you guys later peace